voilà un sujet qu'il est intéressant sur
ses nouveaux smartphones de samsung
samsung galaxy s 21 s 21
plus je sais pas si vous vous intéressez
à l'activité des smartphones je sais pas
si vous vous passionnez de ma femme
voilà c'est super intéressant parce que
d'année en année on voit ça me saoule
faire évoluer sa gamme on est ici dans
le très haut de gamme on est dans le
premium alors vous me direz que c'est ça
le souffle il ya encore plus premium que
le premium c'est le ultra samsung galaxy
s 21 autres afghans n'est déjà parlé le
jour montrent s est en ligne vous pouvez
dès maintenant aller le voir bien
évidemment parce que c'est très
intéressant ça nous montre en tout cas
un instant t début 2021 seul est capable
de faire samsung sur son plus beau
smartphone et ça c'est vachement bien
alors aujourd'hui on ne parle pas
d'ultra aujourd'hui on parle des samsung
galaxy ace 21 ici sur ma gauche et sur
ma droite le samsung galaxy s 21 plus de
smartphones qui se ressemblent
énormément c'est la raison pour laquelle
je les traite ensemble autant entre le s
ventes atteint plus d'un côté et les
ultras du lot
vous avez vraiment de grosses
différences ici par contre vous avez
deux smartphones très semblable vous
avez uniquement trois points de
différence et je vais vous les énumérer
tout de suite comme ça on se met dedans
vous savez on est au courant
bam et ça c'est génial mais avant tout
génériques
[Musique]
ça roule
alors on va tout et de commencer par ça
vous êtes tous noté là-dessus break
c'est ma feuille de notes
voilà plusieurs j'ai plein de feuilles
de prise de notes mais là j'ai les
différences entre le samsung galaxy s 21
et le s 21
plus les différences vont se faire tout
d'abord sur le format s 21 est ce matin
un plus
il existe différentes couleurs ça vous
pouvez choisir là j'ai les mêmes
couleurs donc c'est très sympa comme ça
on compare ce qui est comparable
es21 va être forcément plus petit que
s-21 plus vous avez un smartphone avec
un écran de 6,2 pouces tandis que
l'autre côté vous avez d'une 6,7 pouces
sinon les technologies sont exactement
les mêmes écrans infiniti au pourquoi
infiniti haut mais parce que vous avez
en haut là juste là
ce petit point sont j'avais espéré que
samsung en 2021 nous sorte un écran sans
absolument aucun trou sans poinçon
encoches sans rien ce n'est pas encore
le cas je pense que technologies ne sont
pas encore prêts d'ailleurs je vous ai
fait une vidéo il ya quelques jours je
vous présentais le premier smartphone
avec une caméra cachée sous l'écran czt
utile le fais je vous mets le lien je ne
sais pas par ici ou dans les
descriptions tout cas je vous mets le
lien quelques pas à les voir c'est assez
intéressant c'est pas encore
suffisamment bien aboutie pour que ce
soit intégrable sur des flagships en
tout cas bruits montrent qu'on peut le
faire donc la techno et la techno arrive
et ça c'est cool mais l'a pour l'instant
2020 et bien vous n'avez pas de
smartphone avec des caméras intégrées
sous l'écran donc ça on verra l'année
prochaine en 2022 c'est aujourd'hui une
vidéo qui est réalisé en partenariat
avec rideau schyle parce qu'avoir des
baux smartphone samsung galaxy s 21 s-21
plus c'est bien mais il faut quand même
venir les protéger ça peut venir éviter
les déconvenues et pour ça on a plein de
belles coques sherin au chili a commencé
par des coques nasa oui si vous aimez
l'espace et bien vous allez voir leurs
protégés avec une coque approuvé par la
nasa
si vous êtes plus sport basket et bien
vous avez aussi la coque chicago bulls
et vous en avez plein dans l'univers de
hunter hunter vous avez fortnight vous
avez plein de coqs ça ce sont les
solides suite qui sont très résistantes
est vraiment très cool et si vous voulez
continuer à avoir le dos de votre
smartphone eh bien vous avez de la
crasse gars vous avez du mode enix vous
avez différentes couleurs ou à venir
tous plus tôt misé tout modifier et
pensez aussi à protéger la vente votre
smartphone grâce aux protections d'écran
ça ce sont les impacts
finn protector s'écrit ici l'ensemble
ans comme le port salut qui vous avez
plein de choses pour venir penser à
protéger votre smartphone grâce à
rideaux chine je vous invite à venir
découvrir toutes les cordes de chez
rhinochill toutes les offres et tout ce
qu'il vous propose que ce soit pour le
samsung galaxy s 20 heures elle
souhaitait un plus et même pour plein
d'autres smartphones parce que oui il y
en a plein d'autres
une fois de plus le lien est en bas dans
la description à l'étape du coup d'oeil
que vous allez voir vous serez pas déçus
et cela très très bel écran infiniti
haut comme je vous le disais et surtout
vous avez cette nouvelle dalle c'est la
dynamique amoled 2 x est une évolution
de la taille d'un niqab oued que vous
aviez déjà et dernière avec les samsung
notamment galaxy s 20s 20 plus elle vend
un ultra très belle dalle très bien
calibrée donc ça ça marche extrêmement
bien
le deuxième point de différence acquis
pour moi extrêmement intéressant et
c'est un des points qui permet de
différencier le prix entre ces deux
produits puisque vous vous en douterez
le s 21 a coûté moins cher que le s 21
plus et bien sûr le s-21 vous avez un
doute polycarbonate le polycarbonate
c'est quoi vous irez et bien c'est du
plastique donc là vous avez un d'eau en
plastique
savez-vous cours allaient l'année
dernière sur le samsung galaxy note vain
puisque ça tout nous avait mis à dos en
plastique au lieu de mettre un dos en
verre je trouve ça pas terrible bien je
me dis qu'avoir un smartphone a
quasiment 1000 euros avec un doigt en
plastique et ben ça me fait un peu râler
quand et là je vous donnais mon retour
sur ce nouveau plastique baisse le dos
en verre qu'on a sur le samsung galaxy s
21 plus différence de matériaux mais
regardez c'est super intéressant parce
que en fait à l'oeil nu
on va pas vraiment différence on va
avoir une petite différence sur la façon
dont ils vont renvoyer la lumière au
toucher on sent pas réellement grosse
différence de température on sent
effectivement que le verre est un peu
plus froid que le plastique et puis la
dernière différence avec la capacité de
la batterie soit samsung galaxy s 21
vous avez batterie du 4 mai 2010 en
perdant ce qui est déjà très bien tandis
que 60 ou galaxy s 21 de plus une plus
grosse batterie 4800 milliampères heures
il va falloir alimenter l'écran qui va
être un peu plus grands qui va consommer
davantage
mais l'idée avec cette plus grosse
batterie c'est que vous amènera un peu
plus loin au niveau de l'autonomie
donc on a ces trois points de différence
principaux et puis le quatrième s'est
pas réellement lié au produit en
lui-même c'est le prix forcément es21
plus
va être plus cher que le s 21 mais ça on
le regarde à la fin de la vidéo parce
qu'on a plein de choses à raconter
notamment par rapport à la gamme s vin
de l'année dernière parce qu'il ya eu
une revisite de samsung au niveau de ses
prix donc ça c'est super cool on va
essayer de comprendre quels produits
intéressants lequel produit peut être
fait pour vous quelles sont réellement
les différences est ce que ces
différences sont suffisamment
significative pour se diriger sur un
produit plutôt que sur l'autre ces deux
smartphones sont des smartphones qui
sont extrêmement complet vraiment très
complet on l'est dans le flagship on est
dans le très haut de gamme
ça c'est vachement bien du côté de chez
samsung vous avez une config qui est
super bien pour la photo qui est assez
standard aujourd'hui c'est à dire le
triptyque grand angle ultra grand-angle
tes objectifs
ça marche bien on reste sur la même
config qu'on avait l'année dernière du
côté de chez samsung sur les galaxy s 20
et s 20 + 12 mégapixels 12 mégapixels
pour le grand-angle et ultra grand-angle
et on a un tel objectif avec une caméra
de 64 mégapixels vous venir aller
chercher un petit peu plus loin le rendu
des photos est vraiment bien on retrouve
la signature l'image de samsung avec
beaucoup de détails dans l'image avec
des couleurs qui sont très vives
peut-être certaines fois trop vite par
rapport à certains concurrents ça
dépendra une fois de plus de vous et de
vos goûts mais personnellement les
photos chez samsung marche extrêmement
bien que ce soit sur le capteur
principal ce soit sur le le trac
grand-angle mails sur le téléobjectif
alors attention ici vous avez un zoom
optique x 3 c'est là vous aurez le
meilleur rendu vous pouvez monter
jusqu'en x 30
mais il ya un moment ça va piquer et la
qualité sera plus nécessairement la
samsung 2021 nous a proposé une nouvelle
génération de capteurs capteront
toujours plus de lumière plus de détails
qui permettront d'aller plus loin donc
on a une vraie évolution par rapport au
samsung galaxy s 20 sans avoir une
révolution pour autant sur la vidéo
c'est aussi un excellent smartphone plus
beaux films jusqu'en 4k à 60 images par
seconde
surtout les capteurs le rendu est cool
le rendu est honnête boue est montée
jusqu'à huit cas à 24 images par seconde
il si vous n'avez absolument aucune
stabilisation
reste à savoir si pour vous les 8 15 est
intéressante pour moi ça reste vraiment
une fois de plus j'avais déjà 10 en 2020
ça reste à peu près la même chose en
2021 on reste sur un usage ni celle d'un
mois de procès sur vous et derrière les
xenos 2100 vous permet de le faire donc
bon pourquoi pas donc là on sent un
petit test en 8k 24 images par seconde
cela nous fait voir la vue qui est assez
sympa ici sur la cathédrale de clermont
ça va être le fera que je crois là bas
et là c'est la terrasse d'un de mes
potes avec bien évidemment les toilettes
sans rooftop et puis là bas le petit
barbecue sympa et là normalement des
plus stabilisée ces deux-là 4k fâché
l'ue a gelé en 60 images par seconde
on voit ça à peu près la même chose
toujours là voilà il ya la poste
derrière toujours ça ici toujours les
pipelines juste là et puis toujours la
balle la galice qui est en train de
cuire vous avez le mode single take 2.0
qui revue et améliorée non ça
fonctionnera pas mal
vous avez une mode du réalisateur c'est
pas mal ça vous permet d'avoir les deux
caméras qui vont superposés caméra
arrière et caméras de celle fille à
l'arrière vous pouvez naviguer très
facilement et switcher entre vos
différentes caméras soient vont avoir de
grand temps que soit votre tas grand
temps que soit votre télé objectif est
de notre côté votre caméra telfix bon
voilà c'est truqué un peu rigolo je vous
dirais la même chose que je vous ai dit
lors de mon test du samsung galaxy s 21
ultra c'est dommage que vous ne puissiez
pas exporter individuellement ce qui va
sortir de chaque caméra pour vous sortir
en tout cas de fichiers c'est un peu le
point de regret c'est déjà rigolo comme
ça mais pour moi ça reste un artifice
toute amitié rivest ces cas là je passe
sur le téléobjectif ça t'arrive ça
t'arrive ça j'étais très près cette
vague on est comme ça de près et de loin
de loin c'est pas la même ce qui est
intéressant c'est que vous avez aussi un
mode ultra stabiliser concerne le mode
axel kahn à 60 images par seconde
pourquoi pas et là on est en mode super
stable on est en full hd et aurait à 60
images par seconde et ce qui fait que
généralement en terme de stable je pense
que je suis pas mal vraiment pas mal
donc pour toute la partie des personnes
qui sont très créatives sur la photo et
la vidéo est bien que vous avez de quoi
faire vous avez également un superbe
écran une très belle dalle très très
bien maîtrisé très bien calibrée superbe
expérience lumineux même en plein jour
s'il faut de plus samsung avec sa
dynamique amoled 2 x qui est vraiment
une très belle réussite
la différence que vous avez ici par
rapport au modèle ultra c'est vous ne
pouvez pas être en wqs des plus vous
êtes en full hd plus mais ça marche
vraiment très très bien vous avez un
taux de rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à
120 hertz et du adaptatif sais vous
allez être sûr du 48 hertz au plus bas
jusqu'à 120 hertz lorsque les
applications nécessiteront du sang
valeur sûre du all ways and displays
vous allez allez sur du 48 heures si par
contre vous êtes sur un jeu ou une
application qui nécessitent du 100 verte
et bien ce moment là vous allez monter
en 120 hertz et puis au milieu vous
trouve également du 60è du 90 e en
fonction des besoins des applications
vous allez utiliser ou des jeux donc
pour toutes les expériences de
navigation et de gaming
ça sera extrêmement fluide et très
plaisant la partie audio est pas mal
pour le multi les dires vous avez des
hauts parleurs stéréo mais vous n'avez
pas la même directivité entre les deux
haut parleurs vous y retrouver bien
évidemment votre haut parleurs qui sert
à vous passez vos appels ici qui servira
de haut parleurs également lorsque vous
allez me regarder un film une série
directement en face comme ça on va pas
avoir la même directivité du son la
leçon va partir plus sur le côté et la
plus comme ça on ne respecte qui sera un
peu moins large sur le haut-parleur de
gauche toute la partie logicielle est
aussi super bien avec manuel 3.1 basé
sur l'android 11 c'est clair net lisible
ça marche vraiment bien et puis surtout
ce sont des smartphones
5 j'ai autant l'année dernière vous avez
deux versions une version 4g glaçons 5g
ça fait beaucoup de versions entre les
seins de son billet ce vin est 20 plus
avec la kadji la 5g ça faisait quatre
versions 4 prix c'est un petit peu un
buvable plus les déclinaisons niveau du
stockage
c'était compliqué en 2020 l'an 2000 21
c'est simple c'est de la 5g partout mais
parce qu'il ya toujours un mais il ya
toujours des mais il ya des trucs qui
sont pas parfaits sur ses smartphones
moi j'aurais bien aimé qu'on retrouve à
laser pourquoi pas sur le s 21 plus on a
un laser sur le samsung galaxy s 21
ultra mais on ne l'a pas ici sur le s 21
plus qu'est ce que vous apporte ce laser
et bien il vous permet lorsque vous
faites une photo en mode portrait de
bien venir mesurer la distance entre
l'objectif et entre la personne ou
l'objet que vous aller photographier
pour avoir vraiment une zone qui est net
c'est exactement la même chose pour les
photos de nuit puisque vous avez moins
de lumière et pdca permettra de calculer
ce sera beaucoup plus simple
ici il y en a pas c'est un peu un point
de regret pour voir que ses smartphones
font vraiment axé sur la photo et la
vidéo c'est l'adn de la gamme galaxy s
et samsung
eh bien je trouve qu'il manque un peu un
truc le truc qui me fait un petit peu
râler c'est la disparition du bloc de
charge
c'était la même chose si apple fin 2020
c'est la même chose chez samsung
début 2000 21 voudrait plus de bugs de
charge donc si vous n'avez pas de bloc
de charge qui est compatible avec les
smartphones dans sa chambre comme chargé
jusqu'en 25 watts maximum
eh bien il va falloir en achetant qui
s'appelle retrouver incompatibles je
vous conseille vraiment d'acheter celui
que sale souvent pour éviter les
déconvenues à l'avenir il ya un truc que
samsung nous a retiré ses l extension
carte microsd ça peut paraître un peu
effectivement ridicule et futile mais
vous savez qu'on on garde toujours
à peu près les mêmes tarifs jeudi à peu
près parce que c'est pas exactement ça
mais ça on se développe dans quelques
instants
d'ailleurs c'est plutôt une bonne
surprise on en parle en quelques
instants et bien quand on est dans la
même gamme de smartphones et qu'on en
ait que des choses qu'on enlève le bloc
de charges qu'on aurait dit si
l'extension carte microsd eh bien on se
dit que pour moi que c'est un nouveau
modèle qui peut en faire plus et
parfaite on en fait plus pour north fait
moins on retire des choses comme ça
c'est c'est pareil ça m'embête un peu
alors d'un autre côté vous avez dans les
deux modèles soit 128 giga de stockage
soit 256 go de stockage qui est quand
même relativement énorme
en plus de tout ce que vous allez voir
vente au castrum dont bon voilà sur le
principe ça m'embête comment lever
quelque chose
mais malgré tout dans l' usage normal
manger de quoi faire et puis le dernier
point et ça c'est un des éléments
majeurs en europe et notamment ici en
france et bien vous allez trouver un
processeur exynos et les dinos 2100
alors l'exynos de maison c'est une très
belle évolution par rapport aux 9 190 il
va plus loin il est plus performant mais
les benchmarks en sortie il est moins
performante que le dragon 888 de
qualcomm et ça ça fait toujours un peu
râler sur les versions us et canada sur
ses smartphones là vous avez une version
avec le processeur de qualcomm
snapdragon 888 intégré directement dans
l'es21 plus donc quand vous allez sur
une version européenne
un processeur qui est moins performant
qui ira moins loin qu'il ira moins vite
qui calculera - victimes potentielles
man show fera un peu plus et qui en plus
de ça va venir jouer sur l'autonomie
parce que oui bien évidemment un
processeur ne fait pas que vous apporter
de la vitesse mais il va jouer bien
évidemment sur le calcul au niveau des
photos il va jouer sur l'autonomie un
processeur c'est vraiment à 360° dans un
smartphone dont je trouve ça dommage que
vous ayez deux poids deux mesures chez
samsung
un smartphone qui est extrêmement
performant de l'eau côté de l'atlantique
et notre côté à nous il est très
performant
il est vraiment très très performant
mais il n'est pas aussi performant alors
il ya un autre truc qui m'interpelle
beaucoup c'est sur cette fameuse
question du dos il ya un drop thèse qui
est sorti qui montrent que sur les 3
smartphones s 21 et 21 ans et plus et s
20 heures ultra que je n'ai pas ici les
ont fait tomber je sais plus quelle
hauteur c'est un moine de m est ce lui
qui s'en sortent le mieux
c'est rigolo c'est celui qui a le dos en
plastique le dos en plastique serait
donc plus résistant que le corning
gorilla glass virtus de dernière
génération qui pourtant est donné pour
être plus résistants il s'en sort moins
bien que ça me donne en plastique voyez
comme quoi malgré tout des fois ça c'est
extrêmement intéressant ce que j'aime
bien ici notamment sur nous
r c'est que vous avez un dos andermatt
donc vous laissez pas trace de doigt et
puis toucher vraiment extrêmement
agréable j'aime beaucoup aussi le blog
photo avec cette finition d'étals toute
cette tranche tendent à lui
personnellement c'est extrêmement
premium et j'aime beaucoup et puis bien
évidemment c'est des smartphones qu'il
faut venir protéger et une fois de plus
je vous ai dit le lien en bas dans la
description nos partenaires et nos
shield donc vous le voyez on a des
smartphones qui sont très belle
évolution des samsung galaxy s 20s 20
plus de l'année dernière on n'a pas ici
une révolution dengue dans l'air on
avait été surpris par le samsung s20
ultras qui était nouveau
on va plus à s 21 ultra est une très
belle évolution du s21 ultrasons pour
autant révolutionner l'histoire c'est la
même chose pour ces deux modèles qui
sont de très belles évolutions on va
plus loin on améliore les choses on
corrige différents points mais on va pas
raconter ici une nouvelle histoire après
est ce que c'est vraiment ce qu'on veut
pas nécessairement veut pas avoir une
nouvelle histoire tous les ans on
s'appuie sur les fondamentaux et qui
marche très bien et que maîtrise samsung
met à ces quelques petits points et
j'espère un jour j'espère que ça me
saoule partira chez qualcomm pour
intégrer les derniers processeurs à
moins que samsung réussissent à
surpasser
qualcomm au niveau de ses processeurs
mais pour l'instant c'est toujours pas
le cas quelques petits points en plus
vous avez du wifi si ce smartphone qui
résistant à la poussière et à l'eau ip
68 ans marchait très bien et vous avez
ici un indice de réparabilité de huit
ennemis sionistes et surtout sur les
trois modèles alors le dernier point qui
m'intéresse et non des moindres c'est la
question du talent il falloir regarder
on va répartir déjà ce qu'on avait
l'année dernière ça ce sont les prix
qu'on avait l'année dernière sur le s20
et le s20 plus comme je vous disais
dernière vous aviez deux configurations
une configuration 4g une configuration 5
g sur le s20 vous étiez à 909 euros sans
la version 4g et sur la version s 20 +
1000 ne feront sur la version 5 g vous
étiez à 1900 à 1109 euros sur la version
s 20 plus donc ça c'est super
intéressant vraiment regarder les prix
de cette année un fait
cette année sur le s20 en parle bien du
s21 on parle uniquement que de la 5g ici
la 4g on oubli puisque vous n'avez pas
de version 4 geste sur les samsung
galaxy s 21
donc si vous regardez bien sûr le s 21 5
g sur la version 128 go de stockage
vous n'êtes pas à 1900 euros vous êtes à
59 euros
vous êtes 150 euros moins cher que ce
qu'on vous propose l année dernière sur
l'équivalent 5 g
donc ça c'est vachement bien ça c'est
possible notamment grâce au dos en
plastique grâce au fait de ne plus avoir
carte micro sd grâce au fait de ne plus
avoir bloc de charge et il ya
probablement si des économies d'échelle
que je ne connais pas le gène de
tristane en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que tu arrives il devient
extrêmement intéressant et si vous
regardez du côté du samsung galaxy s 21
ans +5 j'ai 128 go de stockage
une fois de plus eh bien vous êtes à
1059 euros vous êtes donc 50 euros moins
cher par rapport à son équivalent de
l'année dernière donc bon ya pas une
grosse grosse grosse différence du côté
du s21 plus par contre ce qu'on voit
c'est la volonté de samsung devenir
réduire ses tarifs pour s'adapter
je pense en tout cas ça me semble
logique à une concurrence alors après il
ya une espèce de cote mal taillée parce
que bien évidemment il a fallu trouver
un petit peu l'entrevue entre la version
4g et 5g notamment au niveau du s21 plus
mais par contre ce que révèle le tarif
du s21 tout court 128 giga de stockage
cinq gîtes bien évidemment eh bien voyez
c'est qu'on est quand même vachement
moins cher que la version 4g de l'année
dernière on est à 859 euros on est 50
euros moins cher et on et 150 euros
moins cher que la version 5 g ça ça
montre vraiment la volonté de samsung
devenir réorienter ses tarifs à la
baisse
pour gagner des parts marche en tout cas
éviter d'en berne samsung reste leader
incontesté et incontestable au niveau de
la téléphonie mobile dans le monde
entier
en france bien évidemment mais toujours
faire gaffe à passer cette distance et
par la concurrence
d'où le fait de venir repositionner ses
tarifs et ça je trouve ça bien nous
confine à l est ce que c'est dérangeant
d'avoir ce dos en plastique qui va être
plus résistants au final sur un drop
tests que le corning gorilla glass vitus
eh bien voyez c'est une question qui est
extrêmement pertinents je suis pas sûr
parce qu'un côté premium parce que de
toute façon vous allez mettre une coque
de protection derrière donc bon pourquoi
pas personnellement à ce dont je suis
persuadé c'est que pour 95% des usa 99%
des usages vous ne verrez pas
nécessairement de grosses différences
entre le processeur dans exynos et le
processeur qualcomm
c'est surtout une question de technique
dans une question de passionnés de tech
se dire hamas
ils vont plus loin chez qualcomm que ce
qu'on va retrouver sur l'exil aux de
samsung l'un dans l'autre les deux sont
extrêmement performants pour faire
tourner vos jeux pour pouvoir faire
plein de choses ça ira
merveilleusement bien
on parle ici de point de détail et de
personnes qui sont pas sur des tec comme
moi et qui du coup voilà on va mesurer
ça comme ça a vous de me dire vous
maintenant ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire quel smartphone vous
préférez samsung galaxy s 21
s-21 plus est ce que vous pourriez vous
au 707 en sachant qu'une différence de
tarif et je vous les donne quand même
entre la version 128 go et 256 go de
stockage choisissons de s-21 soit 28,7 à
859 euros tandis que s'il voulait 256 go
de stockage vous coûtera 50 euros plus
réfléchie saisir ça c'est quand même
vachement intéressant pour venir doubler
votre stockage et sur la version s 21
+128 vous êtes à 1059 euros il est
probable que 156 de plus et bien il faut
rajouter ici 50 euros également vous
passez à 1109 euros et dernier point qui
est très intéressant c'est si vous avez
un samsung galaxy s 20 est ce que ça me
coûte changé non gardez vos smartphones
minimum 2 ans ne venait pas les changer
tous les ans pour moi ça ne sert
strictement à rien mais si vous avez un
smartphone qui est plus ancien et vous
voulez un smartphone 5g bien ça peut
valoir le coup à se poser la question
est ce que je dois prendre le s20 5g de
l'année dernière ensemble depuis dix ans
les stockages parce que je prends le s
du coup 5gb évidemment sans obliger le
stockage de cette année mes feuilles en
tombe tellement qu'elle n'en peuvent
plus et bien en fait une différence de
prix cassés intéressante parce que j'ai
regardé sur dur conditionné vous pouvez
trouver le s20 128e les stockages 5g à
600 euros tandis que vous le trouverez
en neuf à 725 euros ne fait plus les
liens sont en bas dans la description
d'un vol il ya un delta sur la version 9
s'est pas laissée sans moins
intéressantes sur dur conditionner la
question se pose entre 859 euros sur le
s 21
128 et l'autre côté sur le s20 5 j'ai
128 600 euros voyez là quand même 259
euros d'écart a vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez sur ce genre beaucoup
d'amour des choeurs du love et à très
vite
ciao